I inquired as to whether or not they
were under investigation and the company
confirmed a number of investigations
including this one so that was that was
part of potentially what may have come
out if they had filed their 10k at this
point but they haven't so some of the
stuff that typically shows up there
hasn't come out yet in terms of what's
been going on in the last couple months
of the fourth quarter for other reasons
because they've had to restate earnings
so do they know do we know yet what
they're under investigation for and had
it might compare with salix we don't
know precisely what their investigation
under investigation for though a source
says that it's separate from the salix
investigation it's actually into valiant
um but we don't know what exactly
they're obviously accounting concerns
that have been raised by the Restatement
and their relationship with this
mail-order pharmacy Philidor so that's
the one that's most obvious because
there's been a restatement as a
potential candidate but it's unclear at
this point and of course there were some
headlines just about an hour ago which
Moody said it may cut balance
Pharmaceuticals is rating valine of
course relying on the debt market to
make a lot of its acquisitions yeah
valiant has some 30 billion dollars in
debt right now so the question is how
are they going to pay that back and how
are they going to pay that back if their
business model is constrained and some
of the traditional ways that they have
pulled levers as they've bought
companies and they've grown earnings
that way they've raised prices on drugs
they've already said they're not doing
that anymore so the question is can
their base business grow in an organic
way and it's possible that it can but
they really need to prove that that's
what investors are sitting and waiting
for and that's what there was a call
today that was scheduled for the morning
before they said Mike Pearson was coming
back and I think everyone had been
eagerly awaiting that update to know
what's really going on with the business
and so now we have to wait a little bit
longer they haven't set a date for that
yet but that's what everyone's going to
be looking out for in terms of the
investigation what is next for valiant
what's the process I'm sure they're
going to be questions just into what
exactly it is and they'll be disclosures
at some point that'll probably clarify
some of that so that's just what we'll
have to wait for on that front seeing
what else is to come from that but
really there they have a number of
investigations and legal issues at the
moment that they're dealing with and so
it's not surprising that this is yet
another one that they're going to have
to settle in the next couple months or
even years sometimes things things drag
out so we'll just have to wait and see
unless the stock down at one point was
twenty one percent yeah yeah
the most in 2011 Cynthia thanks very
month my